hello welcome to big mood we're here
we are missing jess today but in her
place we have
kala beautiful finally we're so excited
to have you here we've been wanting to
have you on forever
yes oh you know i came into this space
not too long ago
and i thought to myself well i got angry
at bryce and i think george i was like
that's easy does their [ __ ] look like
this and we have folding chairs
like literally we have folding chairs
where we're sitting this low and our
guts are just hanging out well you have
cool
you have uh didn't you have a pool in
the background well we didn't have a
choice we had nowhere else to record oh
gotcha
they didn't even give you a building no
they didn't and then the first one it
was like a low rider seat and i remember
annie just yelling at everyone
oh my god puppy yeah so we have another
guest um
yeah cola paula is our security guard
she likes to come by and like she's
chilling like jess is in here
okay i'll fill in i'm blonde i'm cute
that's our that's our blonde for the day
adorable okay
yeah i guess like for context though
because maybe people don't know
you have your own podcast yes i have two
two podcasts yes you have
tiger belly i have tiger belly with my
um gargoyle lover
bobby and i have he's a girl he loves
gargoyles
he could be more of a gargoyle if he
tries
got it okay i've seen the red in his
eyes before he should be atop
a building just like lurking um and i
just started a new one with my friends
esther pavitsky and annie letterman
i think annie's been on the show yeah
she's a wild boar
yeah and i think esther's coming on soon
too so nice we'll have all of you
also blood bat well both of those shows
are produced by
the same producers we have bryce and
george
um they're like hey we need another
women's podcast so they
they'll fight each other in in combat i
think i think that's their ultimate plan
well let me tell you how it's backfired
the fighting happens
on our podcast esther and annie could
not be more
unlike each other like esther's sort of
like this sweet little
she keeps it nice and pg for everyone
and annie
yeah yeah how would you describe
yourself then oh i'm i think that i'm
the referee i'm just right in the middle
and um i cannot like they are the
funniest
it's like it's like a a car crash like i
can't
peel my eyes off from like they're just
bad i feel like you're the grounding
force though i watched a couple episodes
and i was like okay i kind of
i get the dynamic i really like the
dynamic too because it's like you all
bring
a special something um where yeah like
you said they're
they're very opposite and then you're
kind of like the grounding force
it's like you're reeling it back in
sometimes but i love your stories
like you just casually drop things like
i was watching one where she just they
didn't go into it they
she just casually dropped that she was
like trying to be part in the olympics
for the philippines and
um something else happened and then it
went off into this other story and i was
like what the [ __ ]
filipino right yes half are you full i'm
half
okay yeah but i grew up there until i
was 15. right i did not i grew up in
america but i was always jealous of your
type of girls when i first came here
yeah how come i was always jealous of
like asian girls that were so like
assimilated to american culture because
i was a fob
and i was labeled a fob gina i know you
know you did she terrorized fobs
she terrorized abg's come on
no i mean they were cool um they were
there would be like very
like super fresh off the boat kids
chinese kids at my school because you
know like in my neighborhoods like the
rich chinese kids that come over
and it's it's fun because they would
always pick their own american names
and then this girl she barely spoke
english but she told me she's like i
chose my name i'm like oh [ __ ] dude
what's it gonna be she goes dicky
oh well that's nice but let's
not you know yeah i was nice to them
yeah what do i look like a fob
terrorizer
you look like a [ __ ] riser she's like
you look like the girls at school that
picked
them flashbacks like i have a sweat
mustache now i'm like gina is a trigger
no i was a goth kid in high school like
we were same everyone yeah
yeah we got along with with everyone but
that took a while because i remember an
elementary feeling very
lonely like um i was i just wanted a
community so
even though i was very americanized um
like i wasn't white
so white kids would always be like where
are you from you know
and then assume that you were um latina
probably no
they would like they thought i was from
a different country oh wow so i got that
yeah so i got that one yeah yeah well
then also then i even wanted to fit in
with them because our school was half
mexicans half white
and i was like well i want to spit in
with the mexicans then if like
i'm not i'm not white um i could fit in
with them and they were they would speak
spanish
and then i was like okay well i don't
speak spanish so
i'll just go play with toys over here in
this corner
i went the other direction so i went
full mexican okay
like i was a chola i speak spanish nice
i made out with everyone's uncles
i have the biggest um um playlist of
just all like the spanish hits that i
feel nostalgic oh my god tell me which
ones because
just this week literally just this week
i've been i've been making it a mission
to get closer to my culture because i
completely like detached
being with my husband who's only he's
chinese yeah so i
realized like oh my god there's a huge
there's a huge hole in my life
uh of my culture missing so i've been
trying to like find all the old spanish
songs that i used to listen to so
can i give you my playlist yeah that's
my last ball playlist because in my
school it was
half black half latino so it was we
every year we had a latin american
school association the last of all
and it was the best that's so cool that
is amazing yeah so
i was fully mexican i think that now i
would have i would have been cancelled
a thousand percent for cultural
appropriation it's all i identified with
because they were the ones that like
fully embraced me they were like you're
from somewhere
probably you don't probably know but we
don't care yeah yeah
yeah like that familiar that happened
when i got older yeah yeah which was
awesome
but trolls were always the nicest yeah
you anyways
two things about cholos they love
camping
they'll never cheat on you yeah like i
had so many cholo boyfriends
my last one victor his name was puppet
oh my god
my dad knew a guy in prison named puppet
everyone knows a little puppet i can
already picture his knee-high socks
yeah you know him he called me like a
couple years ago and he
he called me because he had just gotten
out from jail and he asked if he could
name his firstborn kalila
oh i almost didn't pick up he was like
hey it's victor
and i i was so happy to hear from him
just because like all the feelings
rushed back
us like biking together oh that was
really sweet
that's cute so he named his daughter
kalyla i said yeah you can but so if
there's another kalila out there it's
probably his kids oh that's awesome
see how she did it again like let's talk
about the olympics like why are you
trying to not talk about the olympics
um the olympics the olympics i didn't
make it so it doesn't count okay
well we didn't make it
i was a part of the philippine national
team for most of my childhood up until i
retired
so and i went to a division one um
school i got a full ride to unlv
what sport was it swimming oh swimming
wow and um so i did that and
i spent my whole life thinking that i
was for sure gonna make the olympics
and i didn't and it was the biggest
heartbreak of my life oh man
i know i can't imagine it was very close
it wasn't even because i
i didn't actually like make the time cut
it was a a thing with
um philippines and finances and all of
that oh
man yeah so you were worthy but you just
weren't able you were swim worthy
you're worthy to us but you ended up um
studying well
like filipino uh nursing or are you a
nurse right
um yeah so i went i got my bachelor's in
nursing from cal state long beach yeah
and then when i met bobby he was like
are you sure you want to do that
and i'm like are you trying to derail my
life because my mom's about to stab
you trying to tell her daughter not to
become a nurse
you got to follow the footsteps of all
the filipinos maybe yeah i know i have
shame you're going to be a nurse or a
mailman
standing now yeah yeah singers yeah
singers great singers the lead singer of
journey is filipino now
that's awesome i followed his story even
the guy from blue's clues he's not a
singer
got pacquiao yeah pacquiao um
are you super filipino like do you speak
it do you think she's she
lived there until she was 15. that's
right unlike tiff yeah he only tries to
trick us all the time
you so know
clear that i only spent one year in
mexico my entire 15th year
no but everyone's like no she was born
and raised in mexico
my sister was born was born in mexico oh
that's cool what city
um
um yeah but i was i was born in the
philippines i'm telling you gina i was a
full-on
like very fresh off the boat so how did
your mom and dad meet
and my dad worked um he worked for the
us government for a long time he was
kind of his weird james bonzi type came
from money and then he went to the
philippines that's sexy
lived for a year doing whatever and then
he met my mom
and it's kind of
it looks from afar like an old guy just
scoring a young filipina
yeah so it's like a 90-day fiance type
thing yeah it's hard for me
to like i sometimes feel like i
misrepresent their love because it's
that's not what it was like they stayed
together until he died
and um but from afar it looks like that
yeah okay yeah i know it's it's
it sucks because if it's that it if it
looks like that people just
automatically assume it's that right
and that's do you guys watch 90 day i do
i've seen snippets of here and there
what
that big dead guy whatever in the
philippines thick neck head thick neck
edge shorten that good yeah
but that girl is thriving now she's
thriving i see her on tick-tock
ed on your podcast yeah it was
terrifying
i was terrified why were you so scared
um
i was just um i didn't like him on the
show yeah
and then you have to be gracious when
he's on and i think that he's a sweet
guy it's just
um i was very team rosemary because i'm
like damn like you just [ __ ] on her
breath
you [ __ ] on everything you know and she
had to explain how she had an ulcer and
on
for all americans to watch you know yeah
like you there's certain things he did
that i was like come on guy
yeah i'm not a fan did you drill him on
that when he was on the show um i
i did i think towards the end but i was
kicking myself for not like
defending her more but i'm just not like
a super
like in the moment conflict type yeah
it's hard when they're they're guests on
your show and it's like
yeah and yeah you're not like the
controversial type
have you guys like um been through that
where you've had a guest like you
you've disliked but you just kind of
grin and bear it
i played the fifth not on our show
really
you played the fifth i would say no no
no we always like try
to get people that we as far as
for me speaking for myself like we
always get people that we feel like we
can
either relate to or are very interested
in their story
and we really are not on this show yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'll talk about this yeah
this i just win my head cause i've been
on so many different
i'm like yeah yeah there was many many
times where i had to bite my tongue
oh in other shows no no yeah but i'm
talking about this no not the show
yeah in other shows yes but here we
we're we're pretty good at it i mean
until today
um i also read that you're a scorpio so
we're pretty much the same people like
oh we're half filipino scorpio we
haven't met until now i know me neither
i always thought there was something
kindred have you even met i feel like
you've met
steve i haven't met you you haven't no
okay i've never met steve
to be fair i'm kind of a hermit and i
mean nowhere to be found
same that's the reason why like i'm
usually the hermit in this whole group
yeah like i pop into our group chat once
a month yeah
so for me to meet you first it's like
really weird yeah you meet anyone first
i'm like you guys are sending me
that's really true yeah so how did you
guys meet
a few a few weeks ago yeah and then you
smashed bobby
wait hold on you guys played together in
call of duty i did oh correction i did
not smash bobby
but um yeah you guys played together and
was he just
really horrible or did he live up to
your he held his own
just fine thank god because he spends
most of his time most of his time gaming
right
yeah he was really nervous he's like
babe i'm going downstairs to play with
gina i was like don't let us down don't
let this family down
represent our family but i think he did
okay right yeah oh i didn't know he was
nervous maybe that's why he was a little
quiet
because you were like oh cause remember
he was like snipers or cowards yeah you
were like
no that's called strategy i saved his
ass once
that's why he was nervous so quiet oh
that's kind of cute yeah that is cute
i don't picture him as a nervous guy
when i think about him
but she was on jk right yeah girl i i
beat you guys oh okay
i i won i've met kalila like a few years
ago
maybe four ish four years ago and when i
did jk i was
such a stiff and i was because i'm just
not and this is like you were a man wait
i was like kaleila please come back oh
my god you're yes oh i've only heard the
best about you and i watched the
episodes of
bloodbath and i was like you're great
like you know you're such a good
conversationalist yeah
yeah you have so many stories i'm like
you need to write a book she also like
i think because you're so casual about
it that you don't understand how
interesting you are like i think that's
like uh
bobby taught me that he's like if you
put it all out there no one can hold it
over your head
yeah and um but there is a drawback to
that which is
something i talk about in therapy where
i'm like i don't know what parts of me i
still own
oh yeah i gotta relate so i relate to
that too so hard
right yeah so that gets a little bit
tricky especially on like
you know days where i feel a little
bluer than others yeah i'm like have i
just
put it all out there sold all the bits
special bits and pieces and intimate
parts of myself
mm-hmm you know to the interwebs i
totally get that
yeah because when when i first started
it was acting
only like well stand up and acting yeah
so it was like a persona right
or i'm playing a character um but then
entering the youtube world where it's
like personality based content
it was really scary like um because
you're like sharing
parts of your real life um and it's not
in a bit form it's not like a
set you know where i'm i'm still in
control over it
um but i do find the more that i've put
out there
the more it's really helped people and
that part
is what i think i think it's worth
it for all of that oh yeah um but i i
know exactly what you're talking about
where and it's scary because
we're continually evolving the things
that i'm learning today
like do not reflect the things that i
said five years ago like i talked about
like wanting to beat my children i
talked about
you know trans people in a way that
wasn't you know
kind like it's just some really
hacky totally i mean so
in the old days before the internet you
would
be saying that stuff on a stage or
whatever like you would get it all out
maybe
it didn't land that well or maybe you
made a bad joke or maybe you're like oh
[ __ ] that's not how i feel anymore
and no one ever sees it again it was
like one night you
said it like if you're doing stand-up or
you know podcasting it's important
but yeah on the internet it's like
forever and it's like
it's like you've people can't ever
change their mind about something either
like if you said something if you had an
opinion
10 years ago you never got any new
information you could you're
not allowed to change your mind that is
who you are forever especially if that's
a person
they've like if they've been hurt by it
like i got a
an email yesterday by um a trans person
saying like hey episode
80 like we're in up to episode 300
something like you said this
and it's horrible what you said and i'm
and i'm like yeah
it's horrible what i said it well i
didn't say anyth it was more like
callous and kind of jokey
but still it like someone felt accosted
by it yeah and i cringed and i felt like
oh [ __ ] like
how many things of that nature did i say
back then that i can't even recall
saying yeah is what i can't i have a
troll i have trouble reconciling with
because it's hours hundreds of hours of
you just
stream of consciousness and there's a
danger to that i think
yeah i get that especially so with jk
news
you know we're reacting to news articles
that come up
and i've most of the time i've never
heard the article beforehand like we're
like it's brand new like this is what
happened and you're just like a first
reaction
like oh [ __ ] like here's my first
reaction to that story
and then like later pieces of
information that you've gotten not even
the whole story
yeah just from a piece of information
i'm like oh [ __ ] like that's cr
this is how i feel about this story and
then later you find out more information
and you're like oh [ __ ]
well that changes things i feel the
complete other way but i'm not on camera
anymore
so i changed i was like oh i got new
information i'm changing my mind on this
story i feel like i support this person
now but forever
you get messages like how could you say
that when
you know did you even know that this
this this and this i'm like well yeah i
know that
now it was a first reaction to the
pieces of information i was getting
but yeah it's it's frustrating are you
guys sensitive to
like comments and things that are like
negative
i know gina you're off you are just
three
you have a full-on body armor like yeah
she gets more energy
i'm so in awe
suck your blood and like put it into my
body
like can we just like can you want to
ask one day yeah
but to have any part of you it would be
so lucky
oh my god so i don't i'm not that lucky
okay but um
good good health bad colon bad colon i
think i
drank too much i ran my body to the
ground in my 20s
yeah well if you guys do if you do blood
sucking ass night i just want to
um like vlog it so we can get a good
thumbnail going
we can pass out drinks okay wait you
know adam and eve has been around for 50
years we can find a three-way dildo
it could be a four lady party i just
want to go win
i'll hold it stick and it will just spin
you know beautiful just holding it yeah
that's how we're going to power the
electricity from now on just
butthole power why can't i picture it
why do i why am i able to picture it in
my mind too
man oh man am i hungry and when i'm
hungry i'm cranky
i don't want to go cook food because i'm
mad at the everything
in the world at the at the spices in my
kitchen that don't make
a meal um so what i do
is you don't want to be around me gina
i've seen you you cry on the floor i do
i cry when i'm mad i cry
it's very counterintuitive but doordash
came to our rescue or more so my
husband's rescue
because they are able to drop off food
right to the door
just like in the name and it's all the
restaurants i love
right now right in my mouth so
[Laughter]
now you can get grocery essentials you
need to withdraw dash you can get drinks
snacks and other household items
delivered in under an hour
ordering is easy you just open the app
choose what you want where you want and
your items will be left safely outside
your door with the contactless delivery
drop-off setting
there's over 300 000 partners in the u.s
puerto rico canada australia
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national
national restaurant chains like popeyes
chipotle
and cheesecake factory for a limited
time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood
that's 25 off up to a 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood
like my mood when i'm hungry we're 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
don't you think your butt would be
cleaner if you cleaned it with water and
not just a piece of dry toilet paper oh
yeah
yes and that's why everyone needs a
bidet i've been preaching about bidets
for years
you have right i just thought you were
really fancy i was like well i can't i
can't get one in my bathroom
gina i don't have an outlet but now you
can without an outlet
and it's mother's day soon too so bring
your mom into the future with a brand
new hello tissue 3.0
modern bidet attachment it's stylish
eco-friendly
easy to install and will help stop
flushing her retirement down the toilet
and tp costs
i see what they did there hello tissue
3.0 cleans
your butt like a champ but doesn't stop
there it cleans itself
with a smart spray automatic
self-cleaning nozzle
when we say anyone can put this together
we also mean
your parents the ones who always lose a
remote control
yes yours hello tissue 3.0
hello tishi 3.0 attaches to their
existing toilet with no electricity
no extra plumbing or tech support face
times and cuts toilet paper use by
80 percent so the health tissue bidet
pays for itself
in only a few months plus every
hellotissue bidet
attachment comes with a 60-day risk-free
guarantee
and a 12-month warranty give the gift of
a clean butt butt
go to hellotushy.com big mood to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners
at hellotishie.com big mood for 10
off again that's hellotissue.com big
mood
for ten percent off your butt butt now
you're about the bidet for your butt
butt
your butt butt is priceless what are
things you are afraid of gina
uh i do not like motorcycles right
specifically like the crotch rocket
like motorcycles that was from trauma
that was yeah i lost someone yeah oh god
yeah
yeah one of those uh with my therapist
i've
learned that one of my greatest fears in
life is that i'll never be safe
because i was i never had a safe
upbringing a safe childhood or a safe
person so i'm very terrified of that and
like safe in what way like with men or
just like your physical like dangers
around you
uh especially men yeah because i was
abused
when i was a kid for like the longest
time yeah by like the men that were
supposed to protect me not my dad my
dad's [ __ ] cool i love him
but like uh other men in the family and
so
i didn't i didn't grow up with parents
my dad was in prison my mom was off
doing her things i grew up with
grandparents
i was never safe so what we learned was
i am afraid of not being safe and i am
any problems that i have from my past
only manifests
in romantic relationships oh that's
interesting yeah that's why i keep
my my romantic relationships extremely
private on social media
until recently of course you know about
that yeah
all of them you want to catch the t
follow gina's tick tock
yeah she was wild and that was the first
time i ever came out publicly with any
specific person that i'm dating because
before it was just like oh i did this
with an x or that with an x but i never
really named anyone
until then until now um good for you
[ __ ] him [ __ ] yeah
yeah okay and you know what's funny is
that like we've all
known guys like that yeah that's not a
one-and-done
situation there are so many like that
which is wild because on the episode i
was on with you guys
we were talking about how korean dads
are crazy and they beat their sons and
stuff like that it was this
same story with him and how he was like
um absolutely destroyed because he found
out
at 17 years old his dad had a whole
second family and he was cheating well
mom and stuff and i was like oh so you
just became exactly what your dad was
yeah
like i read him and i don't know if this
is
um you guys can cut this out but i i
read him as a classic narcissist
yes and it's like maybe you were um
praised
only for the big stuff but emotionally
neglected that's how i read him
or in the gas lighting that's that's the
part that gives it away
of like the narcissism is like like
how how could you not trust me you have
trust issues
you you have a problem like you have the
trust issues you're crazy it was wild
and like i didn't
the thing is he treated me so different
than all the other girls like completely
different he made himself exactly what i
needed what i wanted
so it was a very strange feeling to find
all this out and realize that
this was a completely made-up person
yeah yeah that's shattering i dated the
same guy
not the same guy but it's the same guy
oh you smashed
we're all smashing each other's
boyfriends
yeah um but as for like social media
comments i don't really give a [ __ ]
because i've been a creature of the
internet for the longest time even
before
making it my career job or anything yeah
i have a lot to learn from you i think
in that way because i'm a really
sensitive um sensitive person when it
comes to that
bryce will tell you how many times i've
been like i'm not built for this
and um but i'm still not um
but it's just you know i really hard
yeah yeah
i'm very sensitive too um but you're
like not supposed to
show it because then like they know your
weak spots and then they'll just keep
harping on you but yeah like i would say
that
i've been same like on the internet for
so long i was
uh eminem forums yeah and a [ __ ] nerd
i was like 14.
you guys had computers because i didn't
it was very
it's very slow dial up that sucks to be
an immigrant
are you gonna get that second generation
yeah at the computer lab trying to log
in
you guys have computer labs yeah
i didn't get my first computer until i
was 21 i think oh wow
good wow and it was like a hand me down
it was like one of those bulky macs with
like the blue bags i can't believe your
parents didn't make you build one or
something
[Laughter]
no you you never would go to those like
internet cafes like you'd go to like a
specific
i didn't have any money like we were so
poor
that we just we were just scraping by so
so often that it was like and unless it
was an actual necessity like we would my
sister and i would steal like blocks of
cheese from albertsons wow
any like shrimp crackers for like three
weeks like that kind of poor so no we
didn't have like
you know extra dollars to like spare but
i remember like listening to like my
chemical romance in like
2000 during the emo days and you know
the song i'm not okay
i remember like like just screaming at
top of my lungs because i was
i my my mom said we couldn't afford the
computer yet
i was like
[Laughter]
how am i gonna
wait was it what was that other one the
one that got um napster napster
yeah i used limewire yeah that was the
second one yeah this is like
after napster got sued limewire was
around the time i finally got a computer
in my house
so mine was a hand-me-down from my
grandpa because he was like a tech
nerd guy um but yeah it was like a his
like old old computer
still worked though got to moderate the
eminem forums
but so cool so you guys like got hopped
on aim and all of that stuff yeah
i never even had like yeah i never had
any you never got aim
my first thing my first um
my first experience with like any type
of the internet was friendster
okay yeah you're still old yeah yeah
yeah all right
yeah you got in there yeah yeah facebook
and all that it's before myspace
yeah i'd say that it was kind of a good
thing for you though because i remember
being young on the internet just
watching videos of like
decapitation oh yeah i did dumb [ __ ] i
gave away my address because i thought i
was in love with this guy in a chat room
oh yeah like we sent each other
christmas cards my parents were pissed
i ended up calling him he lived in
philadelphia i thought i was going to
run away and move there and marry him
uh and who was he he was this guy from
the eminem foreign
or like a 40 year old man he was um
so i was 14 and he was 18.
but he said he was 16 and i said i was
16. so he was lying
we were both lying of course how did you
find out his real age
well because we started talking a lot
more and like i realized after talking
to him
he lied about every single thing he'd
ever told me so he was like the internet
they lie on the internet yeah
wow i know right asl
not not real not real um but yeah so i
gave away our
her address and back then like he wasn't
some like old creeper yeah
i know i know right they thought he was
like a young
like that he didn't lie about yeah you
know they can still come and kill you
true he really could when i think back
about
these days like where i was so young and
dumb on the internet i'm so terrified of
having children yeah
same i was young and dumb not on the
internet in real life like i would
hitch a ride oh my god oh my god
yeah i would do that all the time like
with creepy dudes and i would wear
really short shorts
like where you go and i just no uh-huh
all the time
you no dude how are you alive i don't
know
you did this alone because i feel i
would do it i would do it with my sister
in mexico but but we didn't turn that on
how are you i do question that a lot too
but honestly i would
they're i kind of feel safer in the
philippines and mexico because that's
still
something people do like yeah hit your
ride like there's still
culture of like helping people out over
here it's like we have slasher movies
like we don't do that yeah the mines
have been poisoned
we have real life slasher right now but
the way we would do it it wasn't like
hitching a ride it was more like
like manipulation so my sister she would
go up to
people like young ish guys like around
her age who she was four years older
than me so around her age
she would go up to them be like oh my
god have you been i haven't seen you
forever like
oh would you mind like where you headed
because right now me and my sister are
heading this
way would you mind giving us a ride so
she would just pretend to know these
guys and
then she was hot so they would be like
oh yeah [ __ ] i don't remember i must
have
like blacked out at that party when we
met and so they would think that they
knew her and then give us rides genius
yeah girls going places don't do that in
her own car
other people's cars but she's going
places oh my goodness i mean look it was
just a different time
it was we had a whole operation for to
go shopping because we didn't have jobs
you know we're teenagers
um we would go downtown and because like
there were no cell phones
you'd use the pay phone um and so we
would stand by the pay phone we had a
whole operation where we would go
hit up every pay phone stand by it
anyone that walked by we're like
can we have 50 cents to call with my mom
like she needs to pick us up and i lost
my
my money and so like we would panhandle
for quarters to call our parents
and then and so we had like 20 bucks and
then we'd go
shopping yeah so quarters oh yeah yeah
everything was paid for in quarters
that's awesome that's better than
shoplifting which is what i was doing oh
i was tiffany that is
all i did yeah i i would have wire
cutters in my purse
my best friend my best friends is tiny
asia um a korean girl
and no one would suspect her because she
was just like so jesus loving and she
was like
basically like the pastor's favorite and
so we would just send her to sephora and
she would just swipe
oh my god we would steal any type of
alcohol because we found out that you
know like
ralphs or vaughn's employees couldn't
like go after you and chase you in the
parking lot
so you actually literally go to
abercrombie and crack crack with
bolt cutters macy's i was like
i was poor but i wanted you know i
wanted
my echo jacket that's how it is so i
feel like
the poorer you are the more that you
want like i remember when i was broke as
[ __ ] like i was just like man if i had a
hundred dollars i would buy some clothes
right now or if i had a thousand dollars
i can't wait to like
the day i have a thousand dollars so i
could like buy any clothes i want to
but then when you like have money you're
like i don't really
i don't really need that like i can i've
never looked more homeless in my life
yeah i i just want sweatpants i never
want to leave the house
yeah i remember when i was like in my
mid-20s
and getting like the michael kors watch
and then traveling everywhere and making
sure like
an airport like everyone's oh especially
because you're filipino
yeah oh my god all my my my relatives
from the philippines
they would come over here and they would
demand guests like guess was like the
big thing back then
where like you send them guest [ __ ] they
just loved guests but any designer
where it like says the name of the
design like they want to be like
billboards for the designer what i do
before i go to the philippines is i hit
up ross or marshalls
because all of those brand names are
there right yeah like ten bucks discount
yeah i take it back home and they think
that they've just been
gifted the world yeah yeah bring a
couple cans of spam because that's
top shelf stuff put it in the palak
bayon box
buy-in box yeah and that's just you know
like
but but uh there's a part of me that
misses
misses the struggle i miss those days
yes yeah because you you're resourceful
and it's creative on your toes and
really kind of switched on yeah you
don't have time
to let your mind go idle so do you think
that maybe you're a little bit sensitive
to
youtube comments because you feel
misunderstood
like there's so much you had to like
work for and learn in your life
especially being
an immigrant and having to like relearn
a whole different country system
that to get where you're at now it's
like you can be picked apart in an
instant
based off of it it's exactly that it's
like i lived a full
what i thought was a very checkered but
still very
interesting life before i met bobby but
as soon as i was sat next to him as soon
as he said this is my girlfriend
i was relegated to just one thing and i
was
a gold digger and it was like yeah
yeah yeah can relate hard to you yeah
um she is i know she's in texas right
now
but she uh she kind of entered the group
in a similar fashion um with with jake
you know joe
on yes yes okay i know they dated yeah
so she was
kind of a fan of the show but like i
mean she would watch the show like she
like as a viewer and she
felt like she could relate to the people
on it and so she messaged him and
um ended up like coming out and they
they dated and they lived together
but she had a corporate job like she was
yeah she made an mba
yeah she's like she's so i tell she's a
master such a bright girl yeah
together yeah yeah but as soon as she
space started being public
of course it's like you're only with him
for his money which is kind of an insult
to
the guys if they didn't have money like
they wouldn't
they're that ugly yeah they have no
personality in them
yeah so yeah that's i think that
definitely i'm on that same um just tip
where it
just is such a thing i can't seem to
escape
and because in the beginning there's no
way for me to defend myself like
bobby is a you know was you know a
public figure
to be fair he was posting really like
not
choice photos of me at the time and my
tits were real shiny remember that bryce
i did just look like like a hood rat
really
um so you know what you have a limited
time to have nice tits
so i took them out you gotta you have to
yeah i put them in i took them out but
that's oh you mean like
implant took them out wait explain that
how come you took them out
um a lot of people well this is an
exclusive because i've never really said
this or really been honest about it
it's the the removal of my breast was
two part
um part of it was i didn't like the way
i looked
and i felt um i felt like i was getting
some weird strange like symptoms of like
illness and stuff
that was 50 of it but if i'm being
honest 50 of it was
trying to unpretty myself because that's
how deep my insecurity ran like i cried
about it all the time i'm like
i want to wear boy clothes i don't want
to wear shorts i never want to wear
sleeveless on my podcast i'm going to
wear dowdy sweaters
i'm going to be cool like you bobby like
i want them to see that i'm like here
for you because i like love you love you
and i was really
hard for me and i don't know why i
succumbed to that at that time but i did
looking back now it's clear that that's
what happened
and i'm glad i took the tits out because
i do feel better yeah but um
there were many years of me feeling just
so ugly
but because i did it to myself and i
didn't realize that i was actually like
doing it to myself
yeah it was like a rebellion against all
those like gold diggers seeking
validation
like oh she's turned into a [ __ ]
martha she's okay now
you know you're low lowering shots
taking away your shine
for to to feel like to fit into what
they think
is yeah not what they're calling you
know what sucks too
is that you can you can't like talk
about it because it's like oh i'm sorry
you were too pretty
like oh yeah i'm sorry but [ __ ]
let me tell you i wasn't always too
pretty okay had big-ass gums when i came
here
big ass [ __ ] gums it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
and and you know what it's um
yeah like i didn't feel i had a very
short window of feeling pretty and then
i took out that pretty real quick
yeah and even now it's still something i
work one therapy where i'm like
what happened to my self-worth and i did
it with my own hands
yeah you know with the help of you know
the internet but god i feel like i can
relate to you
like so much cry yeah yeah i wanna hug
and cry it out
um so you got a cat yes yes
yes you got two oh wait second one crap
we kicked jess out cause she doesn't
have any cats today
so kitty poo club let me tell you about
it it's convenient
it's all in one monthly and it's a
litter box solution
what it what you're gonna get in the
mail is an affordable
high quality recyclable litter box
that's pre-filled with the litter of
your choice
you can choose like if you want the clay
kind or the
or the crystal kind or yeah whatever you
want it's a godsend because those litter
boxes
get so gross and then you gotta clean
the litter box
ugh no no no these boxes are leak-proof
eco-friendly and have a fun design for
every season
and when the month's up you just recycle
the box and kitty poo club will
automatically deliver a new one to you
no changing used litter and no more
cleaning the box you can customize your
order based on how many cats you have
and
you choose from four different litter
types and there is a no risk
satisfaction guarantee that you can
easily customize or cancel anytime
and right now kitty poop club is
offering you 20 off your first order
plus a free
dome free scoop and free shipping that's
a lot of free
when you when you set up autoship by
going to kittypooclub.com
mood so just go to kittypooclub.com
mood to get 20 off your first order plus
a free dome scoop
and free shipping when you set up
autoship that's kittypoo
club.com
sweet do you guys ever think about
what's in your deodorant
no no i do think about people how they
smell terribly and they should use
deodorant though
yeah they should have my expo talking
about the aluminum elements yeah did you
guys know that
a lot of antiperspirant they have that
aluminum
parabens talc yeah they're disgusting
ingredients they end up clogging up your
pores you can't even
it's disgusting right but not native
native here is made with ingredients
that you've actually heard of like
coconut oil and shea butter
and it's also vegan and never ever
tested on animals which we really
appreciate yes
there's a reason why native has over 16
000
5 star reviews it's because it works
with over 10 cents including their
classic and rotating seasonals you're
guaranteed to find one you love
their classic scents include coconut and
vanilla which is the most popular
lavender and rose cucumber and mint and
citrus
and herbal musk which i think is a
favorite here we
love that musk smell it smells delicious
but maybe you're you're more into your
natural scent
if so native has a popular unscented
option
and if you're more sensitive you could
check out their sensitive collection
that's made without baking soda
there's no risk to try free shipping on
every order
in the united states and native offers
30 day free returns and exchanges
in the us make the switch to native
today by going to native nativedeo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls
at checkout and get 20 off your first
order
that's nativedeo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for 20
off your first order but no i i i never
talk about this either because it just
feels like
you're just calling yourself like pretty
or whatever but i grew up really goofy
looking like really [ __ ]
off and like i was a moderator of an m m
board okay like
i was pale as [ __ ] in high school talk
about the history of that yeah that was
so interesting
races i was like 50 pounds overweight
like it was like i was not ever the
pretty popular girl
ever at like some point in high school i
got a boyfriend he was also
large like we were not like the pretty
couple
right and then i think i felt so
comfortable like being in a relationship
um that like i was just like thriving
and i
lost a lot of weight and the braces came
off
but i didn't know i transformed like i
didn't know people saw me differently
so i still felt like the [ __ ] goofy
ass like girl
and i couldn't make eye contact with
people i was so [ __ ] shy and awkward
like
i was just really like weird and then
this popular guy
like tried to date me and he ended up
like telling me everything that was
wrong with me and how [ __ ]
awful and like how awkward i am and that
he said i have a have a mustache like oh
like just picked apart
like i walk funny like i'm pigeon toed
me too
really oh my god oh my god you're told
my feet can go in this way
yes same like all the way around like
it's like that
i don't know did you walk
[Music]
[Laughter]
my mom's white though so oh well she so
she says she's my mom
but they partied hard in the 70s in the
80s too many
drugs yeah so
yeah when i pursued acting i was like
okay well i'm never gonna be the pretty
person like i
i don't want to be i was doing stand-up
as like
goofy girl next like the neighbor the
neighbor chick
right like it's like i'm the best friend
like not i don't want to be the lead
girl i want to be the best friend
and i kept getting sent out for like the
hot girl roles and this is where i'm
like
i'm not calling me hot this is what
happened when i moved to la
and i didn't know how to be a hot girl
so i would be in a room
with really [ __ ] stunning women and i
felt like the nerdy little sister again
like where i don't know how to
be hot so i would be like in the casting
room
and the reviews were basically like to
my management like
she we can't put the pieces together
like she doesn't
yeah like whatever is going on on the
outside is not matching
the inside so it's not gonna read on
film like
no one's gonna buy her as the popular
girl
once she opens her mouth i did a whole
sketch about it later but
um but yeah so then uh so then i would i
would
do private sessions with my acting coach
and i cried for like a year because i
couldn't
be that and so i just went the stand-up
route where like i
tried to unpretty everything like wear
hooded sweatshirts no makeup like um
jeans
converse like just be more browy
you know and brilly thing yeah
yeah and but then i didn't fit in there
either because they don't buy that you
were ever
you know the awkward girl you know so
yeah there's that there's that
yeah but then you can't talk about it
because you're like well i'm
well they don't don't know what i am
anymore yeah the way i prove it is like
i let my my ugly young girl pictures fly
same if you don't if you don't believe
me here and then you know how like there
are supermodels like i was once an ugly
duckling and they showed their pictures
and it's always like
you know a picture of them like the
breeze in there and the light all
perfect i mean you were just never that
yeah but the truth is and maybe you can
insert this
bryce i'll send you guys a picture i
want to see this it was not great
it was not [ __ ] great you guys and in
fact i'll send you
the picture of me when i first came to
america and
it's shocking i want to see these
pictures yeah yeah i had
retainers over gums like they weren't
even over the teeth that's how big my
gums were
did your gums get straight well
no they got cut out yeah they do that
wait
what happens you can cut your gum to
shave your gums they shave it down
yeah yeah well i only had like a
millimeter of teeth left
because you had babies because i had
braces too young in the philippines some
orthodontists
were savage paper nine you're ready for
braces
i know and so i had them for three years
and then when i
and they were like oh here's some
retainers i'm like okay i'm going to
america and they're like finding
orthodontists there because your shit's
[ __ ] up
and finally when i saw one they were
like what did they do to you i don't
know
i was just all all gone were in the
philippines did you grow up
cebu like this is beautiful that was
nice
that's where my grandma's from really
she speaks visaya
i don't know actually okay so here's why
none of the kids know
tavalic is because she came here and she
cannot
speak english very well but she will not
speak tagalog in front of anybody so
surprising yeah she was like my kids
will be americanized like they will
assimilate
they will be accepted as americans so um
she only spoke english like she just
worked her ass off trying to only speak
english
and my it's just my dad ended up going
to school like with this
thick ass filipino accent
it's like only english but only english
yeah because that's the only english she
knew
but she was like they're gonna fit in
they're gonna be fine
that's like that's like i think a lot of
um immigrant
parents yeah they're like you know they
would rather die than their kids not
assimilate fully into being american
um and it's sad which is yeah it's
really sad it's said especially now and
it's like i wish i had more
more culture like yeah i'll take you
back home with me baby yeah i'll take
all you guys
can we go because i have a girlfriend
out there she has a big new trip
she has like the biggest podcast in the
philippines oh cool oh my [ __ ] like
um she's what's her name
i don't think i know her yeah so she and
i became like soul mates we met each
other online we're like holy [ __ ] we're
the same person i feel like gina you're
so filipino to me
i grew up yeah all filipinos and all my
best friends are filipinos didn't you
tweet about wanting to marry a filipino
guy yeah i'd like i'm destined to marry
one
now that i think about like probably not
anymore but when i was younger it was
just all filipinos
taiwanese husbands how many i loved
these guys taiwanese guys taiwanese guys
so sweet yeah yeah interesting i learned
a little bit of tagalog when i used to
work at the hospital because all my god
oh yeah the nurses
yeah they were all filipino so i would
love to
lucky and try to remember what i used to
i'll do some rosetta stone before we go
it's also like so easy to pick up
because i know spanish and then
the other way around too right because
especially my dialect like all the
numbers are in spanish the days of the
week
the the months of the year sunday right
sunday's different um
so what's in spanish it's um domingo
mingo domingo same yeah
not in tagalog but
no but speaking about the not having
your culture though i
relate to that a lot too because like
i've talked about earlier
on how i just kind of detached from my
culture unintentionally and i didn't
realize it because i
am a product of my environment more than
like me
being like my family wasn't really
ingraining
our culture it was more like i grew up
in a predominantly mexican
culture like mexican city right so a lot
of
my friends they would be the ones in
ingraining my culture in me kind of
thing
and uh and so because i'm not in that
environment anymore i'm not with anyone
that's
mexican around me anymore i don't really
have that
anymore so you're losing it i'm losing
it and also
i i completely just
gave up on trying to incorporate my
culture and my my language
spanish into my son and so now he's 13
and he doesn't know
any spanish like he's he's there have
been moments in
in the past that he has been ashamed of
being half mexican
and because all he knows about mexicans
is that they're ghetto or whatever like
whatever he's he's been exposed to
via the media or whatever right um
because his dad's peruvian so whatever
he
whatever he's heard from peruvian side
about mexicans and like
because his dad they do have a lot more
family members that they're able to
really
integrate within themselves and on my
side all he
has is just me and and like the one time
we go visit
in mexico it's like all he sees so that
really gets me
really sad and i kick myself in the butt
a lot it's like
[ __ ] why didn't i why didn't i like keep
it more alive like but you know what
tiff like
what 13 year old truly loves who they
are right
like no matter true it's there's just
not a chance in hell
that they're going to really like lean
into
who they are until later on when you're
like oh that's actually a positive like
even for me when i first came here
i was so conscious of my accent that i
started like talking like a valley girl
like i would just mimic
shows and then like i would
first i would have like this hybrid
filipino like
uh mexican accent and then i would
go into a valley girl depending on who i
was speaking to i was just so
in this like identity limbo yeah and
you're just
straddling the line of like where the
[ __ ] do i belong so like you
you hate all the parts of yourself it's
not until later where you're like
this is tiring i'm just gonna commit to
what i am but that doesn't come too
later so i mean he's 13
you know yeah i think for me like the
part that i'm just so like ah tiff what
the [ __ ] is because i have always
been so [ __ ] proud of who i am of
being half mexican half
like you know mexican american is what i
mean like half culturally
but i've always been so proud i've
always loved my food like i've always
been very like
proud and so to not pass that on to my
own kid i'm like damn it
i failed i failed you or i failed you
he's gonna like it later though
because like that's what i'm saying like
up until this point i failed you because
now i'm like i'm remembering like um
like i recently bought loteria which is
like the mexican bingo
and just last night i was going through
all the cards like trying to teach him
like the translations of each
card and be like just trying to get him
to
to accept it more but yeah he's a 13
year old so he's just like
whatever but yeah but yeah and then like
you know we're trying to have more kids
so i'm like i don't want to
fail you know he's going to be hella
mexican yeah
yeah because i don't even remember a lot
of [ __ ] spanish words i'm like god
damn
like a part of me is gone and it's
really sad so i'm like so then hearing
that about your grandma i'm like 10 is
[ __ ] tragic it's really sad yeah
i mean i totally get i i get both sides
because it's like
i get the the people that come over like
immigrants that want to retain their
culture and then i get the ones that are
like
we gotta fit in and i don't know if
there there's no right way
because either way the grass is always
greener like i wish that
had more culture um but also yeah
growing up i didn't there were no
filipinos around
at all so i didn't even know what i was
i was like
are they making up my hair because they
called things
weird like my parents called your um
vagina like a punani
and the penis was a pacoy and so when we
learned
about vaginas and penises were like
that's not what it's called it's called
it's called hunanian gina and her
everybody was like making fun of me
they're like no you're dumb you know and
i was like [ __ ] they lied to me
so then i thought that they lied about
like
filipino must be called something else
because i have not met another one
besides
the filipinos that are in our family
philippines
filipinos so you never visited the
homeland
well no and not until like um 2018 i had
a layover
in the philippines in manila but it was
like
um yeah it was just like the airport
nino aquino airport is chaos
yeah i'm frightened of that airport it's
like it's really a great airport but
manila in general is like a really big
like metropolis and it's
yeah so populated traffic everywhere so
yeah like i would
my i wouldn't suggest landing there
first
and at that time there were i don't know
if you remember but there were like
terrorists on the beach or something oh
yeah it was like during that time where
like you
weren't supposed to go there well the
the south
there's always stories circulating about
the uh you know how lack
or unsafe the philippines is but it's
just no different than it is here i
think that there's a whole lot of
like the government the president's a
[ __ ] up dude for sure
and there's a lot of like um extra
judicial killings there that are
happening
so the last time i went back home and i
think it was 2018 too
it felt a little bit different but
i still didn't feel like unsafe in any
way
and i think that's just like what
foreigners like they always just do yeah
it's kind of like mexico it's like
cartels are in every corner i [ __ ]
love mexico
i believe no but i was gonna ask what
was the reason why you
ended up moving to the u.s i have a
feeling you've talked about this in the
past
but i'm not sure my my dad got really
poor he went from being
a really wealthy guy from like old old
money parents
like and he came to he went to asia as
like a millionaire
lived out like a baller life made some
really bad investments he was a gambler
put all his money in mexico that's why
he my sister was born there
and he made he put like 90 of all of his
money into like he got like a tip
it was like some enron [ __ ] and the peso
crashed in the 80s
so um because he served in the us
military
he thought the only way to survive was
to
take his family to america and live off
like veterans pay
and hopefully have his daughters like
swim their way to college which we did
oh nice so we got like scholarships and
stuff since there's a swimmer too huh
yeah cool but we went from like being
really rich to like overnight
like wow oh [ __ ] do you remember that
change
yeah like you know you had we call him
yayas but we had basically like manny's
always around at driver everything and
then
when we came to america we lived in like
a one bedroom
i remember the rent was like my dad was
cutting a check for like 300 bucks
that would be so much harder to go from
from being really rich to
poor like shit's creek i was watching
[ __ ] screaming i was like
i was like that would be so much harder
because being always poor
like i mean i grew up like pretty poor
like but i mean my parents grew up
poorer
so you know it was a little bit of a
better situation but yeah we were i grew
up in a garage in my grandma's garage um
and then like we moved into like a
one-bedroom apartment
um but yeah i i feel like
okay like i'm slowly progressing
but like if you started up here and then
um i think the change happened when i
was my dad's um ship
we had like my dad had like shipping
vessels and stuff like cargo ships
and um i remember
just one week my dad was like i gotta go
back to the states so he he was here for
about two years before bringing us over
and um he i'm forever grateful
this um nigerian mennonite church funded
and paid for our tickets to come to the
united states because my dad
was a [ __ ] con man and he pretended
like he was agnostic
an atheist but he was like these people
are really nice
and they're willing to like do a
fundraiser and so he became like an
elder in this like
all black church oh my god oh wow and he
it wasn't he loved these people but and
when he died they all came to like his
service and whatnot
but um yeah like when we landed in
america like this whole like church
congregation like greeted us at lax
and um my dad had conned the church to
buy her oh my gosh
our tickets to america and then i
remember driving through
um downtown l.a at night or even from
the plane when you see just the vastness
of l.a and the like yeah
oh my god and you're old enough to know
what that things are changing in your
life
and the idea in america is so like sweet
valley high
you're like i'm gonna date a brad
you know and then so and then we get
thrown into this one-bedroom
cockroach-infested place in the hood
they called it the snake pits at the
time and i didn't care i was like
there's a kfc down the street this is
america
and then i my sister and i thought we
were going to go to this school called
la canada which is like predominantly
like white school and
swim for them and because they had a
really like good swim team but they
found out that we lied about our address
so we got
zoned to blair high school and it was no
longer sweet valley high you guys it was
basically the only reference i had at
that time for what that school was
in terms of movies i watched in the
philippines was
dangerous minds with michelle pfeiffer
but it was the best thing that could
have happened to me like who i became
in that school and being street smart
and just being this like down to earth
kind of like
hood chick yeah was the best thing for
me for sure
like i could have been a snotty little
[ __ ] yeah you know
you never see it till later yep yeah
you're like oh [ __ ]
i guess that was good all that worked
out all that trauma was worth it
yeah for sure how about with your sister
like what was the age
difference she's only a year older than
me so she she's my ride or died we went
through all of this together
and um yeah it's um
it it was very weird it i'm considered a
1.5
because i came here old enough to
remember my my mother culture
and then try to assimilate to this new
one so straddling that line
is something that's not talked about
because there aren't enough 1.50 around
but it's a very very um isolating place
to be because you're neither accepted by
the filipinos who have assimilated to
america
um and you're united they just don't
know what you are
yeah they don't know where to place you
mm-hmm all right mexican shirt took me
and so
yeah that's where i live yeah yeah
the sweetest i had a bunch of questions
playing but i like where the
conversation went
um i was gonna ask you about uh
you know what i was gonna ask you if you
could come back
for another episode of course you guys
this went by so fast yeah
okay so i was gonna ask her any
questions for you guys because i feel
like
it's just hard sometimes like you know
you were just like a guest on our show
like i had so many i was just like
foaming at the mouth i'm like i need to
know more but then bobby like
you know because he's he's a pro like if
you don't ask it then
yeah like i just feel like oh he's just
gonna railroad whatever thought i had
and by the time he asked the question
i've forgotten my question
yeah i'll go on blood or blah blah oh my
god
hang out there yes please that would be
amazing yeah yeah cause
um he dropped some like so many things
that i was like we have to
unpack that um where like she says that
she does like
historical role play with bobby yeah
i'm sorry what now yeah see that's what
i'm saying like there's interesting [ __ ]
going on over here
just imagine bobbing like those white
powdered wigs
well no he's a shoemaker no not excuse
me no
he made you made a shoemaker he's the
aristocrat i was
i was making him clogs that were
breathable
you guys don't you uh role play at all i
do but not
not historical well that's because you
still love your man
i can't look at him he's got to be
somebody else for me to have sex with
him
like who are you today it can't be bobby
it could be anyone but bob you guys
dress up or is it just all like
we don't dress up but we commit we
commit to the characters
and he's i'm sure he's tired of [ __ ]
me so i've got to be somebody
so i gotta once in a while i've
[Laughter]
you should open up like a like a uh what
a suggestion box for people to send in
roles for you guys
oh like a blank in a blank it's going to
get real creepy very fast like hey eat
her fingers
oh you know like we're gonna go full
army hammer like very quickly
so
[Laughter]
okay yes did you hear that bryce
it's on camera and i will take you guys
with me to the motherland
yeah i will um help you reconnect with
your roots nikki
yay gina will be your tagalog translator
you're gonna help me connect to my room
my last of all playlists
i
yeah and um thank you so much for
watching go follow kalila go
watch uh go listen to tiger belly blood
bath all
her podcasts follow her on instagram all
that good stuff
and subscribe and we'll see you next
time bye
we love you bye i love you so much